so we are working on Napoleon as a
seven-part uh limited series uh I knew
him
from the time I made Raiders I met him
on on the L Street lot when he was
preparing the shining and I Was
preparing Raiders of the Lost Ark and we
met in the I think November 1979 he
invited me to his house for supper that
night and we remained close friends
until the day he died and the only film
we ever discussed doing together was AI
artificial intelligence but we are
mounting a big production uh with a
cooperation of uh Christian Kubrick and
Jan Harlan were mounting a large
production for HBO on based on Stanley's
original script Napoleon
so we are working on Napoleon as a
seven-part limited series
yeah yeah
[Applause]
thank you